hi there my name is carson you're
watching the iced coffee hour
this podcast has made three bajillion
dollars
i think that's the closest we've had yet
oh yeah believe it or not you almost
guessed it like on the dot yeah wow 184
thousand dollars really yeah i thought
it would have been higher
well you know it's january or no it's
march ad rates are low you know yeah so
i feel that it's okay
what's up hey
good to have you on thank you so much
for coming how was the trip over here it
was pretty good i i flew over uh today
from south carolina
uh
a pretty easy flight just connecting
flight i mean i'm happy to be here cool
thanks so much for coming on yeah this
is uh it's an honor man uh i think we
should probably provide a synopsis of
who who you are
why you're here this is uh carson from
call me carson on on youtube and twitch
sometimes hi and uh yeah he makes videos
about like video games and stuff like
that
and uh you have a pretty cult-like
following with your audience
some would say some would say and you've
done some pretty incredible things on
youtube well thank you i appreciate that
of course and we want to go into how you
built this business and this following
and uh yeah because we're interested
yeah sure what do you say if someone
asks you what you do how do you respond
to that
oh man that's a good question uh it
depends on the person yeah because i
mean there's so many people that like
don't understand like what youtube is
still to this day like and even people
that do understand they're just they
think of the big youtubers
um i would probably just
in general tell people i do online
content creation and then they're like
what what do you mean and i say i do
youtube and then like um
and that's that's like the bare minimum
uh for someone that's like a little more
informed like right now i'm basically
just a streamer uh and i i post my
stream highlights to youtube
um
and that's what i've been doing for like
the last six months um
that
that's the the basic synopsis i would
say how do you get started doing that
ooh
well i've been doing youtube since i was
like
12 yeah i mean
don't tell anyone because you're not
allowed to you're not allowed to make an
account but i was on someone else's
account so yeah yeah well actually at
first
i was on my dad you're like
book em come on in
get in guys that's why i
formed the place you made an account
when you were 12.
i i i started doing minecraft videos in
like
uh 2012 and i i kind of just kept doing
youtube up until
i kind of blew up around 2018 making
like discord videos uh i don't know
what are discord videos so discord is uh
it's it's a platform
it's like skype but for gamers i mean
have you ever used discord a few times
yeah we have one and we've had one for
like three years but graham's probably
been on there four times okay oh yeah
i've gone live you've had me doing live
yeah he went live
you went live on discord yeah what for
no no not like your type of live like he
just joined a voice call oh
yeah
he went live and did a q a we got like
20 000 people on the discord like it's a
pretty popping discord yeah i'm not
really shy
it's been a while i don't know if i'd
consider it popping yeah
okay come on come on people are probably
railing off all of your big inside jokes
in there right yeah i don't know but it
was pumping for a while i just haven't
promoted but yeah i liked uh and then
clubhouse took over i uh
went to clubhouse for a little bit going
live on there yeah like mickey mouse
clubhouse was club you don't know a
clubhouse yes that was like the social
media platform that blew up what was it
like probably eight months ago a year
ago
and it was basically like you see these
chat rooms it's very similar to discord
really yeah and you see these chat rooms
and you just join and you're a listener
unless if you get moved to a post oh
it's like twitter spaces
i don't know what that is you don't know
what twitter space is no
come on guys you don't know what
clubhouse is
it blew up but now it's just completely
it sounds like it sounds like clubhouse
is just twitter spaces okay probably
yeah uh because it works the exact same
way okay um
yeah
but anyway you were making these videos
what sort of videos are you making uh
comedy
they're
they're basically just me hopping to
call with friends and then looking at
something and reacting to it like
mystery science theater if you guys are
familiar with that there's is that a
dated reference don't know it i don't
know you got to explain it
okay well mystery science theater was
like uh it was mystery science theater
3000 they were like popular in the 90s
um and they
it was
a guy and his two robot friends that
would go and watch really bad movies and
then commentate throughout the entire
thing
and i kind of relate my content to that
because
i'm just doing it like in a modern way
where it's like i'm going on discord and
and getting a couple friends and a call
and then looking at like stupid images
you know um or
i i did a bunch of videos where i went
in discord servers and ran bits
um
and that's what blew you up after six
years of making content on youtube uh
yeah i think so is that right yeah did
you did you did you research me no i
think you just said it i don't know 2012
to 2018. i can't do math so six years
listen i dropped out of college you did
yes when uh that would have been
2018
and what what caused you to drop out
well i mean
it was because i started blowing up on
youtube so i went back for my sophomore
year of college and then i i went for a
month and i had like 300 000 subs at the
time and i was looking at the money i'm
like it's
it's just too good of an opportunity
how much money was it it wasn't even i
mean this was like i was making probably
six 6k 7k a month yeah at the time um
which is good but it's not like it's not
like some of the numbers i've seen now
um
and and i was just sitting there i was
like
i can just come back to college later
and pay for it if i if i run this
youtube thing
and i want to do this so why not yep um
so i dropped out uh of college then i
was actually going for pretty much the
same thing
i was going to be in media
communications so i mean it was it was
just a no-brainer yeah right
interesting
six years that's a lot of time to devote
to something that probably wasn't paying
out for a pretty long time yeah what was
your did you have a schedule back then
were you taking it seriously was it uh i
was into hobbies yeah i mean it was it
was mostly like oh i want to be a big
youtuber that sounds fun
uh and then i'd go up in front of my
class and then you know show a terrible
video and and then people would be like
he's the youtuber in high school how
many subs you had
in high school
i probably got like
three thousand four thousand off of
minecraft videos decent though yeah well
i i was doing it for a long time yeah um
and like most of the subs were dead in
the water so it
i was probably i was probably pulling
like a hundred 200 views a video most of
the time were you ever embarrassed
because i didn't tell a single soul i
did youtube videos i was so embarrassed
that they would find a video of mine
uh
i
i've
there's been times where i've been
embarrassed but i think i think i've
always liked doing youtube too much
for me to care that much about that yep
um it's
it's always just kind of been
very
creatively fulfilling for me
in a lot of ways especially because like
i'm just the stuff i put up is basically
just what i do anyways
like i i a lot of times it's just me
sitting down and playing a video game
and i enjoy the sharing of that
experience with a lot of people and i
think i have a decent eye for like what
makes something funny in in in the
moment while playing a video game or
with friends
um
so i i would do it
even if i i think i would do it even if
i i didn't have subscribers or was
gaining money or anything from it that's
interesting so after six years of doing
this you dropped out of college and
how seriously did you take it at that
point where you're like i gotta double
down the content i gotta do more oh how
do you maximize that so okay well that's
that's funny that you mentioned that
okay
so let me set the stage
the year is 2018 again
uh so like
during my freshman year of college uh
i was i was sitting back and i i was not
having a good time in college because i
felt like
i i could be doing more with my youtube
and i went to my parents uh before the
end of my freshman year and i did a
powerpoint presentation i i laid out
here's here's how much i think i could
make as this for doing this as a summer
job and taking this seriously
and
i i had a whole powerpoint presentation
i i showed off friends of mine who who
were bigger youtubers than me and what
they were making
and i i took that opportunity and and
and
really just expanded on that
and then they said they said yes and i
started pumping out content
that summer and that's what led me to
blowing up
because i i had a whole new idea for how
to do my stuff and that's when i started
doing the discord videos
um
and and i was like pumping those out at
like at least one a week but first i
want to thank our sponsor ftx us jack i
recently started trading crypto but by
the time i got hit with all those fees i
was out of money well why don't you go
ahead and use ftx they are crypto
exchange with no fees whatsoever all you
have to do is download the ftx app and
you can start buying and selling crypto
in minutes and they're trusted by over
six million people to buy sell and keep
track of all their favorite
cryptocurrencies the ftx app gives you
important news updates and news feeds
directly from the top crypto projects
and for every trade that you make over
ten dollars you have a chance to earn
free crypto with fdx you can set up
recurring buys allowing you to invest
money directly from your bank account
automatically every single month other
crypto exchanges charge fees anytime you
make a crypto transaction withdraw money
or basically do anything but the ftx app
has no fees whatsoever and is completely
free and ftx offers a crypto friendly
debit card allowing you to spend crypto
at millions of merchants worldwide you
can also use the ftx app to buy your
favorite nfts with no gas fees
supporting both the ethereum and solana
blockchains so start trading crypto and
nfts with no fees today by downloading
the ftx app and we have a link down
below in the description again guys the
link is down below in the description to
start trading crypto and nfts with no
fees using ftx thank you so much ftx and
back to the podcast what was that like
for you what was the first video that
took off uh
so it was actually kind of like a set of
videos but there was one that initially
boosted me like
3 000 subs which was really big at the
time it was probably like 18 000 to 21
um
and it was the first invading discord
servers video which i i mentioned
earlier where i i went in two discord
servers
the it sounds like i'm i'm like being a
pill and rating people but what i was
really doing was just like trying to
make them laugh by by going in with with
a with a little comedy routine a little
bit
um
and
uh something about it really
stuck with people because no one had
seen anything like that at the time
and
it it just it popped off and then i did
another one and that's the one that
really pumped it like i went from
probably 40 000 to 100 000 subscribers
in in like
a week
jeez yeah it was like 15 000 subs and it
was it was absurd what was going through
your mind when that happened
i was like
i was like finally i did this you know
because it had been like it had been my
goal for so long to be able to do that
and i was just proud of myself from from
for
finally
like proving to myself that i could do
it
um
and i was just happy it was cool can you
talk about your income throughout all of
this like obviously you know when we
first started finance podcasts
we want to know how much money you make
okay well through spend
okay well
like through 2018 i don't think i made
that much
like i could pull up the numbers if you
guys really want me to but it was
probably like i probably made like 60
70k just in 2018 and that was like the
second half of the year but still you
must have been 20 at the time yeah i was
yeah i was really young 20 years i don't
think i was even 20. yeah i was 19. yeah
19 in college that may as well be a
million bucks right yeah and then uh
2019
it was was when it really
was like that's a lot of money yeah i
sat down
and i'm sure i'm sure there was a point
that that you you you i mean i don't
know about you but you hit with with the
money from youtube where you're like
well unless you already had a ton of
money i don't i don't actually know uh
well
it started adding up to be something
substantial but yeah um but it ramped up
so gradually i feel like
what was the what was the time when you
were like okay like this is getting
serious it was it was the first day i
made i think it was like
i had only been doing youtube i think
for three months and there was one day
after three months where it made 180 in
a day
and that to me was the first point was
like oh wow like i could actually make
money doing this yeah that's pretty
incredible and that's the point i knew i
really gotta take that very seriously
before then i was posting two to three
videos a week but there was no set
schedule i was like i'm gonna post this
morning and i would just post it uh but
when that came up i was like oh wow it's
like it's adding up but it's just to me
it was more fun to make internet money
it's less that like you know when you
sell a house or you lease a place like
you get a commission or you're investing
and you get a you know return but this
was like it's it was almost like
imaginary money because right on the
internet it's something different about
it that it's like internet do you play
video games no okay do you play video
games i used to a lot okay yeah it's
like it really feels like a video game
when when you're making youtube money
because because it is it is like an
imaginary thing it's it's because
like sometimes
youtube is just like yeah we'll just
give you
extra money for this video for no reason
and you're like
why
i didn't do anything different what
changed
but like you want to know why and and
i i've always found it fun to try to up
those numbers because it's like a video
game for me
um and did you guys know i'm a little
bit of a little bit of a gamer are you
i've played video games of course
yeah right
sorry you sometimes occasionally you're
working most of the time right
why don't you play video games um never
been interested i i see for me i look at
video games and i think it's gonna sound
bad this is probably the wrong time to
say this i think i would rather be
it sounds weird i'd rather be doing
something else
that
makes money it makes money wow my
strength is not video games i just after
nintendo 64 that was the last console i
had played
no interest after that interesting yeah
everything for me was focused around
like i'm more into business yeah
i don't know i look at it and i'm like
well if it's not making money it's
taking time away from something else
right well i mean what have you made
what if you made money playing video
games
i wouldn't have an interest in it just i
think
it's just
i think if it was enough you would but
if you know if it was i get bored
because i look at it and think what am i
what am i accomplishing from this
because even if i win the game nothing
even if i win the game then what is that
about the experience
but it's a thing called fun but what do
you do
work what do you guys do for fun so
graham is one of the most worked for yes
graham is one of the most interesting
people that i know because
it's very difficult for him to have fun
outside of work and it just is stuff
that isn't work related he doesn't enjoy
it's it's i've never met anyone like it
it's obviously it's admirable because
it's getting you somewhere but he just
can't sports no no
watching stuff you'd rather be working
you know video games no i i like to
watch a good movie you like to play
music i like music i like the reef
aquarium that you saw when you walked in
actually see it oh yeah i gotta see that
on the way up here
right there right
was it near the shoes yeah i was so
focused on taking off my shoes 300
gallons right yeah big water big water
jug like right when you walk in it's
maybe it's real you know what it's
bailey it was it was the dog yeah the
dog oh my gosh i love that dog that dog
is so cute but no it's it's good i just
get a natural enjoyment from working
okay even even if i'm not like working
working it's like it makes me feel happy
to
clean the house
beat you in mario kart a little bit too
hard when you were yeah
yeah there's one weekend uh this is
years ago but uh the front door
that some painter wanted like 200
dollars to paint the front door i was
like
i don't i'm not going to pay 200 so i
went like i was looking forward to this
like on a saturday because i didn't have
any this is before youtube i was like
i'm gonna paint the door today it's
gonna be really nice i'm gonna get this
door done and go to home depot got the
paint like 30 bucks i painted the door
myself and i felt so accomplished
afterwards that i painted the door
like that well that's what made me feel
like i was alive like i got this door
done dude like i love it i want to like
suck your life blood i cannot do that i
i can do anything but being productive
in a day oh yeah we're we're very
opposite you and i this is so
interesting it's interesting just how
different everybody is yeah because for
me it's just like it's it's easy just
work more oh you don't have enough hours
wake up early work late what about your
weekends just go and work the weekends
no sunday you don't need to you don't
need to hang out friends just cut
everything out and work like to me it
just comes naturally but uh
but i mean like
i think some people
i think some people would look at that
and be like this that's that's not
that's not good for you i'm not i don't
i don't think that does anyone ever tell
you like this is not oh all the time
but like if it's fulfilling for you it
is
i
okay so i have my theories
i've said it before on the podcast and i
will i still believe it i think graham
thinks he likes working what but i don't
think that he actually like i know you
like working right but not to the degree
that you do work it's not healthy you
always look like you got an hour of
sleep the night before
it's like
how could you live like that it's like
it seems unhealthy there are times there
are certainly times that that happens
but
80 of the time dude even my mom said she
was like tuning into a podcast she's
like is graham okay
and i'm like yeah like i think so i
don't know depending what podcast was
that all of a minute all of them dude
i'm sure you could point to a few where
it's been like back to back to back to
back and like after a podcast i gotta
plan a video because i have to film it
for the next day i don't have to i do no
you don't
you set a schedule and you gotta stick
with it that's i'm very much there
that's so dope no you know what it's
moderation working is dope yes and
knowing your hours is dope yes i agree
with that but understanding moderation
and balance in life i think is also
pretty imagine imagine if i gave you
let's say
uh you get one day in front of a big
container of money and you get 24 hours
in that container and you have to grab
as much money as you can after that uh
you know 24 hours is up
you can't go back in the container or
imagine there's a 50 50 chance you could
go back the next day you don't know that
in those 24 hours you say you know what
i'm going to take a nap i don't really
feel like it
i got a 50 50 chance tomorrow of going
back in the container
i don't know i view uh youtube the same
way
that is such a false comparison nothing
is guaranteed
what if okay so what if instead it's
your entire life that you can grab from
that container right and then you in
front of you you have a family you have
vacations you have the time to do it now
before you have the family before you
have kids and all that sort of stuff now
it's time to be in the container i think
i think there there are windows of
opportunities in everyone's life where
you're in a container
and that's and that's your and sometimes
it could be an hour a week it could be a
year it could be ten years but you're in
that container yeah and then those these
opportunities come up and people not you
know sometimes they'll they'll let that
slip or they take it for granted they
get too used to it oh the container i've
been here ten hours oh this feels like
for hour
it's too long i think it's a balance
ground because here's the thing
like jack said that container is there
your entire life so imagine you're just
collecting that money from the container
your entire life you never got to use it
you just spent your entire life
collecting money from a container for no
reason so why not collect money for from
the container for a few days
and then use some of the money and then
come back and collect more money there's
nothing to use there's a couple things i
need to provide for context okay so
graham
said to me a few years ago he wasn't
this way but lately since he started
ramping up production he's been more
irritable sometimes angsty sometimes
very tired people in the office yeah no
he doesn't do that
seriously he doesn't do it no but
seriously um
you know he's been
alex laughs this turns into a cry he's
been angst you know and even like a
little like a little
teenager yeah and and you said you used
to not be like that and then we've been
having problems okay we have this is an
intervention
okay but i need to preface this yeah
after fists whatever it is uh it's
unpopular opinion amongst our audience
to go anything like oh maybe you should
take some time off and work less it
really is i've really yes i've said i've
spoke my mind interesting yes i've said
this before on the podcast and people
say that kid's a slacker he probably
doesn't know what it's like to work a 14
15 hour day and that's not true it's
like for most people they can work more
actually but for graham someone i deeply
care about a good friend of mine
i see you and you look stressed out and
you look
you know anxiety sometimes you're
irritable and annoyed and it's like if
you just took a little bit more time for
yourself but so but you know what but
you can't i don't have the luxury it's
the coffee
there's sometimes not the luxury of that
it's just sometimes you got to get
something done
and that's it and it's just like if i'm
on a schedule and a video has to go out
the next day it doesn't i get it it
doesn't i'm not going to not post if i
posted on time for like five years i've
only missed ever maybe two to three
uploads ever in the five years okay if
he's on a streak i get it i'm on a
streak you're on dude he's on the street
like he's missed uploads like
you missed yeah you have though it's not
a street graham it's not history no this
name name if a video is doing really
well and it's long to sling
purposely yeah and it would be
purposeful if you you do it on purpose
if you know it's the only time i miss an
upload a major holiday like a christmas
i've i posted on new year's day but like
christmas is you know big holidays like
that i'm not going to get views anyway
it's it's strategic oh you think you
won't get views on christmas yeah wait
why yeah views are significantly lower
interesting yeah
it might be a demographic they go down
by like 30 35 on christmas day so i do i
don't want to waste a video that i think
is going to do well on christmas day
because people aren't going to watch it
so i posted the next day my audience is
all like 12 year old boys that have
nothing better to do they got that ipad
they're watching that
yeah they're at dinner
but yeah so like the only times they
don't post are strategic
i don't think i i think
once there was a time
where i i missed an upload because just
like either something wasn't going on or
i didn't have the video ready in time it
was something where i was like i felt
better
missing that post to then get ahead i
think there was one time jack where i i
jack and i had a major discussion about
missing out on oh i think it was that
wednesday where i said to you like i
don't have the video or we were going
out of town or something like that and i
had to get a video ahead and i wasn't
going to be able to do it and the prior
video did well so i was like well if i
missed this upload i'm going to
do the next one and i did yeah so
five years it's just it's just a matter
of when do you take some time for
yourself that's it you don't get off the
horse when the horse is full force you
know if a car's driving on the highway
you're not going to get off in the
middle of the house enough is not an
amount it's a mine it's about but you
know what it's not about enough it's
about you got to carry the streak if
if i've been this disciplined for five
years i'm going to carry it forward and
i know myself once once i
scale back
there's no going back to it right i've
built up to such a momentum
where it's it's only it's only downhill
yeah so it's like if i go down to two a
week i stay into a week if i go down to
one a week it's gonna be impossible for
me to get back to three yeah this is so
interesting okay i've i've been on your
side where i'm where i i'm in the moment
and i'm like i gotta keep pumping stuff
out i
because like this is something i have to
do because i i'm in the container right
and i changed
i
i don't think it's as valuable to to
think of yourself in a container as as
it may seem because
i think i think if you're
you're capable now you're probably going
to be capable later in your life i think
no matter what you can put yourself in
the container you know
it's the abundance mentality that's what
it is i don't know
did you know people say the abundance
mentality i agree with that there's also
but there's also a very tangible
thing right in front of you that's like
well that's you know you have to be real
that sometimes the career of like
athletes musicians actors and that
includes entertainers or influencers on
youtube does not last forever sure very
few people have a career that lasts
longer than 10 years almost nobody has a
career lasting longer five years so it's
you know when you're at that point it's
like well you really got to make the
most of it and i know myself yeah so i
know myself
keep three a week as long as i feasibly
can there's a point i'll go down to two
a week uh-huh i'll do that as long as i
can there's a point i'm gonna want a
week do that as long as i can so you
know i think i think i think that's
valuable i i think
i think you're completely fine and and
listen i see both sides here like i i i
completely understand wanting to keep up
that streak and being motivated to do
that
and
i i think that's great
i just don't think that that's the right
strategy for everyone
um
and i definitely know it's there's
coffee beans in this table yeah yeah you
wouldn't notice that well i
like he said it earlier yeah look right
over here you can see them like way
better oh yeah are they real yeah wow
coffee beans what was i saying
it's not for everybody yeah it's it's uh
sorry
i saw the coffee bean
yeah i i just don't think i just don't
think for me personally that that like
constantly thinking of myself in the
container is is the right way of going
about things
especially because like
in the past you know i i've messed up on
on on numerous occasions and
i know some of that is due to
thinking of myself in the container you
know and and not letting myself breathe
and think through my actions
and
i i never want to put myself back in
that position and
maybe i'll find a way of putting myself
back in the container without it
harming me or people around me
but like for for me that's that's where
i'm at you know
and
i i think it's a valuable discussion to
have i think i think each person
should come to a conclusion of
what
they should do for for their own
container i guess
you know i think that's fair everyone is
different yeah it's just a matter of me
looking out for a friend i just think
yeah never take anything for granted and
things could change very quickly and so
you know when when the sun is shining
you make hay yeah i mean i think this is
valuable though i think i think it's
good that you have a yin to your yang
because i mean like
he's but if if you go
off the deep end and one day you do
start you know you you got a machete you
know
you start
yeah i don't know man
he'll be there to stop you you know yeah
but you know what but you need that push
because there have been times
uh that uh you know i've been pressing
for a podcast i'm like jack we got this
podcast right now which i will i'm gonna
go visit my family that's not true yeah
you did that is an outright lie
and what did we do we filmed it i know
because i pushed jack jack didn't want
to do it because he was visiting his
family do you want me to explain this
story i will explain i'll explain it
better i okay it was getting late the
drive to my family is like five hours it
was 11 a.m 12 00. no it was getting
three for early after and i get very
tired on the road at night and i feel
unsafe
driving past you know leaving here past
like three four because i'm driving at
night and i like to be awake and keen on
the road of course and i didn't want to
wait a long time because then i would
have been sleepy on the road and i don't
like that you're safe and competent i'm
safe and competitive i drive like a
grandma yeah hates it but i do just very
slow graham drives like a crazy man
with his machete in hand it's the yin in
the game
he was like a crazy villain i'm so sorry
but this is the peak dogecoin mania
right before snl and we got the dogecoin
millionaire the guy was on you know cnbc
across every outlet of turning his life
savings into three million dollars he
had him sitting in the living room and
he had the time to do a podcast a peak
snl dogecoin popularity uh-huh like jack
we should do this
i gotta get going i'm gonna visit myself
we gotta do it if we don't do it now i'm
like trust me jack we gotta do it now
i guess how well that episode did was
one of our best performing videos
until that until that point but
sometimes like jack you just got to know
i know you were in that case i will say
you were right but then again i was
going to leave it like eight and you
guys needed me for a bunch of stuff over
and over so i like i was gonna leave at
eight and then i ended up leaving like
five it was like very late so
you were right yes thank you for that
push and uh but see but that's the push
jack needs sometimes because sometimes
well it's not convenient but you gotta
uh and that's it and that so that's the
way i view a lot of youtube is like when
something comes up you have to act on it
someone else will and if you don't take
advantage of the opportunity it's gone
so that that's been a lot of same thing
with um in real estate when i was
working with a lot of clients there were
some opportunities where a client would
call you at the worst time at like
saturday 9 00 p.m hey i want to see this
house right now and you're like i got a
life but no but but part of that is like
if you want those opportunities you have
to act on it and i've sold houses to
people who have called it the worst
times friday you know 9 p.m i've got
plans but the guy's super serious i'm
like i'm gonna cancel the plans i'm
gonna show the house and
some of those turn it out to be either
great relationships great clients great
sales so
it just it depends how badly i guess you
you want that yeah anyway tell us how
much money you were making
so
uh 2018 probably made
70k
2019 probably made like
500k
and then a 2020 probably like
and this is just gross income this is
not counting taxes yeah taxes to knock
that way down because it's all
self-employment
um
but 2020 i think
oh
i think i had
over a million gross i'm not sure
um
but i i'll tell you this i do not have a
million in my bank account yeah where'd
it go
uh
no mostly just taxes i don't i don't
spend my money
except for coming here on your podcast
you're pretty brutal yeah no yeah no uh
because i would imagine you're because i
would imagine your expense is being
pretty low because you don't yeah do you
have a high production cost no graphics
cards are pretty cheap though are pretty
expensive well i i don't buy new pcs
either uh
i i think what i spend most of my money
on is paying editors and paying my
assistant
um
and
that's that's about it like like i
prefer to not put my money into into too
much um and i just have most of it
invested
uh because like
i don't need much yeah i'm i'm plenty
happy just watching anime every day yeah
you know how much how much is your
overhead like in terms of do you do you
rent did you buy a spot car payments oh
no oh my friend warned me about this
question
you're gonna start being you're gonna
start interrogating me let's see uh i
don't i don't have uh anything i live
with my parents okay uh so there's no
rent uh
and i don't have a place or anything um
so i'm not i'm not renting out to anyone
yeah you know i knew this was coming no
i mean it's it's graham's so proud now i
am to make a million dollars
living with your parents
with almost no friends i'm just saying
you want to hear something
it's like that that is what you should
sh i don't want to say that's what you
should do but like i don't have my
driver's license how do you get around
[Laughter]
your mom
the car
i need to go to the pet store
the goldfish needs more food mom
petco now
so hungry
where's the toaster strudel bomb
i'm hungry
no
my parents are super supportive and
the main reason i haven't gotten my
driver's license is just anxiety okay um
and so like i don't
there's there's a couple weeks here and
there where i just don't go out of the
house
um that's that's all of us that's me at
this point really yeah
what
what do you do
on a daily basis i like not leaving the
house well yeah it's awesome right i
like it but it's very easy to get used
to it um like uh yeah so sometimes i i
will go like three to four days without
leaving and at that point it's usually
macy and i will go to a dinner and then
that way it's like you kind of leave the
house
or usually jack and i once a week we
plan uh well we try to plan where we
just grab a dinner and just catch up and
we talk like podcast stuff or strategy
or channel stuff
um so that's usually when i go i don't
know i mean it's it's otherwise there's
everything i need is here i mean the
gym's down the street
walk to that everything's here i just
work and then by the time i'm finished
it's like well you're kind of tired at
that point so
yeah
make food at home so
follow-up question
so you don't have any like office
building or anything everything's here
yeah
why
uh i love i love not having a commute
and i thought interesting i thought
briefly there was a time in 2020 where i
thought
it might be cool to get an office and i
remember uh as an agent i saw this place
and it was like uh one of those
townhouses
right on the beach in marina del rey and
i remember walking to this place and
being blown away by it it was leasing
for like 15 grand a month and it was
incredible it's like
the big sliding doors that opened up and
a foot out with sand and then like 50
feet down was the beach in marina del
rey in california and i thought oh
this would be so cool to lease a place
like that and i could work there all day
and then i'd have more separation
between like when i'm home right because
i had always had an office to go into
and i'd work at the oppenheim group so
i'd go there i'd show some real estate i
would stay late i would plan there but i
would film at home but i still had that
separation between you know i'm home i
could i could film and stuff but i
prefer working in the office so when i
was full-time at home
that first month was a difficult
transition because it's just you kind of
go stir crazy in the house stop leaving
so i thought yeah i'd get an office but
i never did that and then i came to
really enjoy working from home and
everything is here and
if i need to film something really quick
walk down the hallway right anything i
need is right here i guess i love it i
guess the reason i asked is because of
that separation of work and and life but
you really like working i love work
but there is no separation that that is
the downside now it does save me on a on
a commute because it's like well for
where would i find an office you don't
have to live in an office right office
space um
yeah so i'd rather just be here all
things considered and and now i look at
like every
30-minute chunk of time is like that's
something time i could be spent working
so if i'm in the car
you know it's i'm being less productive
but yeah
car time could give you think time i i
like car time but usually once a week
i'll i try to go to the aquarium once a
week the aquarium store oh and uh i i
thought you were i thought you were just
going outside and staring at me
five times no i did that
you get you get your coffee in your hand
he really does oh no that's what
instead of watching tv i just sit there
with it with my coffee okay that's
actually so cool i check everything in
the tank multiple times a day you got to
look at it just checks it that's cool
actually i was upset so the torch coral
one of the torch corals died no way
it's a torch coral so a torch coral it
was a it was a neon green i think it's
called the hulk the whole yeah the whole
torah i'm so sorry man that's okay now i
enjoy it but
you're a confusing human yeah i like i
like stuff that stresses me out like
he's fueled by stress that is what fuels
him like it works
work is a good challenge you should try
youtube drama yeah i don't know
that's right have you thought about
tweeting
gosh you know i yeah
i've said i've stayed off of twitter
i've uh i have a twitter but i rarely
ever post i gotta start posting on that
have you thought about becoming
president of the united states ooh i've
heard that that doesn't make your hair
go gray i actually did i thought for a
long time that was this thing yeah
and the reason why is because i thought
you know i've taken a very middle ground
approach to personal finance it's like
here just the facts this is what you
need to know that's it let's not waste
our time with anything else and i
thought you need a guy like that in uh
in politics so full economic approach
yeah who just could take a sensible
approach to things let's not you know
pander to one side to the other no no
listen to me i thought honestly because
i don't like you know people ask me am i
republican or am i democratic i honestly
have nothing oh i truly had nothing i am
right in the middle and well that's not
going to get you elected well
here's the thing it's like i don't i
don't identify with either side because
i disagree with things on both sides of
course agree with things on both sides
but you have to pick a side or else
you're not going to get it
he's smart like this is i i i appreciate
that and i remember
being in the middle that's good and we
do need someone that's sensible it never
made sense to me to to pick a side
because if you pick a side then it's
like well what if there's something on
that side you disagree with
uh you know are there are there varying
levels to how much you agree with your
side
so i thought
take a middle ground approach that's
what the country needs and uh you know
and this this is a far-off pipe dream
and then i saw our buddy meet kevin uh
run for governor of california oh and
seeing what he went through i'm like no
i cannot yeah i was
just yeah just seeing what what he went
through yeah and all of that i was like
that's governor yeah and that's governor
um now granted that's governor of
california which is extremely i don't
wanna say polarizing but you have people
that really
agree or really disagree
um but i would imagine the same even
more so for the country yeah so i saw
that i'm like no it's not i don't want
that i wanna so i wanna know about your
experience um
living with your parents sure have you
found that that hinders you in any way
to
no they kind of let me do my own thing
okay um
the only i mean
it the only thing is
like
i mean
at some point i want to you know
be a little bit more independent and in
a lot of ways you know i don't think i
want to be 24 25 living with my parents
you know i just don't think it's a good
look
but
um it has disadvantages because i you
know i i get to eat dinner with my
family which is dope and then i get to
go upstairs and and record a
stupid video where i make poop jokes
and you know i'm happy doing it and then
i and then i watch anime for like three
hours i'm curious do they charge you
rent
no so
uh they used to and then
i helped them pay for a house i see okay
yeah and and so like i i don't pay rent
anymore that's good so you paid a
one-time upfront cost yeah
well i was happy
to do it
i was i was like i have the money yeah
like why not got it
i think maybe getting your driver's
license
yeah what's holding you back i mean
we've been saying you know for you know
like six years that i should do that
what if you need to go somewhere where
do you suggest i go on a date
not right now
nothing that's that's a whole that's a
whole debacle are you oh it is
i'm not dating until i'm 35 okay
are you not on dating apps no
why
because i don't want to be
i'm not ready i i don't think i could
see you on a dating app i don't know
really no oh yeah no i think even even
well
i guess for you jack it's like you know
for me are you saying i wouldn't be
successful is that what you no i'm
saying you don't eat it you don't know
wow but someone like me
god yeah i mean like i need all those i
guess i guess who was it that uh
um
i remember seeing some sort of thing
like celebrities on tinder and there
were people on tinder uh in this list
and and i think they were verified but
like he was like why are they on tinder
like that that makes no sense to me well
i know celebrities and just people in la
have their own little yeah raya yeah
right yeah he knows it are you on mariah
they declined me wow i have no idea how
i sign so right you're second on the
second on the side yeah you gotta move
me first
no i mean i guess i do know why i'm not
as popular as the other people on raya
and they have like a list so like they
go through your contacts you like allow
access to your contacts you allow it and
then and then like they're like okay
these are your contacts that are on riot
and then you can like send them so they
can like
you know be like yeah sure jack's with
us sounds dystopian yeah it's very
and you know
gladiator where it's like
i don't know i just want to dude i want
all of them so
why why am i on all of them yeah
um why do you
leave your house why do i leave my house
why do you have your license because
i have my license because my parents
weren't huge fans of driving me places i
get that and i get that yeah but they
still do it
no uh i guess that i like leaving my
house mom i paid for the house
she wants to keep the house
i like to i like to go outside of the
house because it makes me happy like
there was for example this kind of
nuance but like i would say three months
ago i was at the house and i realized i
was so unhappy and i was so lethargic
and i felt sleepy every single day and i
was talking with my housemate i was like
why do i feel like this what's going on
yeah and then i was just like i haven't
left the house in like
a week yeah and i realized that and then
i literally went outside and i sat in
the sun for like
40 minutes and it was like euphoric and
i went inside i immediately felt better
it was like i was vitamin d or whatever
deficient it was weird
i'm with you man but yes
okay come on come on but it it made me
feel so good a little bit more pale
maybe a touch
but i don't know i just went outside and
i felt amazing and it fixed everything
it's crazy wow do you go outside
uh in the sun i try not to honestly yeah
if i do no i'm actually wearing
sunscreen
yeah now i have a so i had a scare where
i convinced myself i had uh
skin cancer like melanoma because my my
grandfather and my grandmother too um
both had melanoma at some point and they
had it removed
um but yeah so i had like so i have
what's called it's called atypical mole
syndrome and it means that i get like a
lot of these little like little dots
everywhere and some of them are bigger
than others um but because there's so
many of them and because they're varying
in sizes and shapes and colors yeah that
i have a higher likelihood of getting
skin cancer gotcha so i got one mole
that i was like oh crap i just convinced
myself because uh my skin was dry in
vegas and i was like it started itching
it's like skincare okay but you have a
valid reason right yeah
but yeah so now now
yeah we just don't like the outdoor well
he likes the outdoors now sometimes he's
a changed man yeah but i will say a more
more vain reason is uh
i got these little wrinkles on the side
of my eyes now
just because i squint so much
and um the sun makes it worse so has
anyone ever told you you have the eyes
of tom cruise yeah yeah that's like you
get it you get a lot i'm so sorry people
commented all the time like he looks
just like
have you guys seen the new batman movie
yes
everyone keeps saying i look like the
riddler
uh i guess yeah
it's just it's just because of the
glasses and i have hair
no it's not it's completely different
shape no slightly same
shape of face slightly and then he also
has a very clean shaven face
um i can kind of see it yeah
i can't grow a beard so yeah
give us the lowdown on the batman do you
recommend it or i love it i love them
you really i really did it's long so i
went into it it's almost 200 minutes
long
and i don't know if i could and
i uh
i thought and i'm not like a big batman
sort of like i i don't really follow it
but
you know like the last two i watch it so
good it's one of the few movies that's
like hooked me from beginning to end did
not feel like i don't know how many
hours imagine how much work you could
have gotten done in 200 minutes
if i add up the cost of my hour per you
know because my time per hour multiplied
by three
yeah wow
you have the numbers and everything
that's probably not healthy
uh i think we should go back to talking
about carson and how you continue to
scale your business what's did you have
like strategies that you employed to to
scale your business what was oh boy oh
no uh no
uh i mean not really i
i it pretty much was just okay i had one
successful youtube channel what do i do
next um
okay i'll make another youtube channel
and do a completely different style of
content that i find fun
and i did that and then it grew my
twitch and then i did that kind of thing
for a while while also doing main
channel occasionally which
maybe i should have done more main
channel or or whatever but
um and then i i did a short sin of doing
merch and stuff like that and and now
i'm kind of passionate about that and i
don't know i i want to dip my toes into
all sorts of little pools or
aquariums if you will
um
but
i mean i don't know exactly what
aquariums i want to dip my toes into
at any given time right now i just made
a minecraft let's play channel
because i just felt like it hmm i don't
know if i'm going to continue it that's
fun it is fun though right yeah so how's
your income broken down between like
youtube twitch sponsorships okay so
i i don't
i don't have any really sponsorships
anymore um right now i'm not making
money because i'm doing a year charity
um
after um it was a whole thing okay um
but uh so everything's everything i make
is is going to a charity each month um
but in the past it was
um
i would make
to give an example it would probably be
like
main channel would make 20 grand
live channel would make
40 grand this is like middle of the year
not not january or february and then
twitch would make
uh 10 to 20 grand and that that
that would pool together and be my my
grand sum of like 80k yeah in a month
um which was
pretty good
i was pretty happy with that
around right now i think we're making
like 20 to 40k a month for the charities
which is pretty good
lois is like 35k
um he does the numbers for me my sorry
my assistant's uh
off camera that i wanted to check on the
numbers
my attorney over here
my my guy
my guy in the chair
um but yeah no it's it's been going
really well
that's good yeah and and
like my numbers are way down once let's
not let's not get around here but that's
completely fine with me because like i'm
still making
pretty good money and
i'm having a good time doing it yeah so
what's your plan after the one year
it just
i don't know yet investing or um i mean
i'm i just have a guy that invests my
money for me uh which i don't know how
you feel about that do you have do you
have a guy
you don't have a guy do you have a
grenade
how do you feel about having a guy that
does the investing for you it depends uh
i think for some people it makes sense
when they want nothing to do with it and
they just say
here's my money allocate it i don't want
to think about it that's me yeah
i want to watch anime
that's what i want to do
and maybe a good thing you don't need a
lot of money to watch anime that's so
true i'm like 10 bucks a month
do you guys watch anime i don't well
yeah there's a there's probably like
five years he's so much more of like a
nerd than you but like you stare at your
aquarium this is so what an interesting
podcast i think we should also talk
about
the rest of your entrepreneurial story
we should talk about carson more is
there anything else that you have to say
what do you mean because your income you
stopped at 2020 right
uh
yeah well
beginning of 2021 um
is when like i took a big break
um and then i came back
september
and and started the year charity stuff
and that's been going pretty well i
think i think we've raised about
250 000
just just
that's that and that's just like from my
revenue you know and that's i'm really
proud of that i think i think that's
sick
and and like
i how how so have you guys done much
charity stuff
i like team c's so i did some tv
stuff yeah
yeah so i saw you did a video and did
you watch it yeah i did wow yeah that's
a
interesting video yeah well i've seen
all the i've seen all the team seized
videos what did you think of my team c's
video it was good
you liked it yeah wow yeah did you see
why i didn't see your team
well it didn't do as well as the other
videos of course not you know but
because i made a fan fiction about mr
beast and mark rober oh
and i and mark rover like comes out of
the seas shirtless and then like maybe i
did see that and then he shoots like a
laser out of his eyes and then was that
a it was that a while ago this was a
this was like team c's so this was like
this was like four or five months ago no
i haven't seen it no okay um and then at
the end mr beast and mark rober uh kiss
and carl jacobs and chandler and
and and they're all there you know
celebrating of of course
they're always there
have you noticed that they're always
there they're always there they're
always there i imagine like mr beast
like tries to go to the bathroom and
then they're they're just always there
they hand them the toilet toilet paper
carl jacobs has the toilet paper in hand
here you go they're just reacting to it
everything is content at that point yeah
the subtitles like just appear in mr
beast's vision
today i am going to the bathroom and the
first person to give me toilet paper
wins ten thousand dollars fifteen
million views but they have the fbi
chasing them so whoever gets here first
wins dude
i would watch that
a lot of people would watch that that
would be funny to do a parody of all
that sort of stuff like the first person
may be a peanut butter jelly sandwich
gets a million dollars go
but there's like an hour
it's so terrifying whenever anyone says
that they've like seen my content
because i'm like what have you seen
which which which video where i did the
stupidest bit have you seen because it's
it's so interesting that you've seen the
mr beast and mark rover video because
that video is is absurd but it doesn't
matter
you know i i think is that what you
watched to get like an idea of me before
the podcast no no i've been familiar
from before the way before the podcast
but uh that was like the latest one a
little while ago i was like just click
it
but um it reminds me very similar to uh
ian idubbbz
and when i when i interested when i
bring up is like i loved your earlier
videos it was crazy when you're unboxing
stuff
and he made it very clearly he's like oh
yeah that's you know that so he's so
normal in person but you would see him
with like lipstick all over you know
going crazy unpacking these things
and uh you know kind of plays into that
character but it's hilarious
but just very different in person like
just a
well-rounded funny guy does that make
that uh your fan interactions kind of
unique oh you say dude fan
oh dude
dude
my fan interactions are weird because
because like okay
today
he he's laughing over there because what
happened today
we're walking into our hotel
two 12 year old kids
i'm assuming 12 year old i i'm just
throwing up a random age and come up and
they're like dude it's call me carson
and their moms with them and one of them
goes up i'm like i'm like holding drinks
because we were getting raising canes um
i i'm awkward especially when it's like
when it's like okay this is this is some
kids with their mom like trying to take
a picture of them taking a selfie with
me and it's like this is this is so
beyond me because like i don't view
myself like that but obviously they do
and and so it's very it's very hard to
know
how to
um appropriately respond to a situation
like that
and i'm not used to it yet you charge
for a picture you say does your mind
charge for a picture
well that's how much a picture is do you
want it i do i do know like pewdiepie
doesn't let people take pictures with
them and and i've thought about it
before i'm like is that what i want to
do
because like there's there's a certain
point where there's reason for that just
because everyone would yeah like if
everyone that doesn't even watch him is
going up to take a picture with him just
because he's pewdiepie why would he want
to and there's no way for him to know
you know
and i kind of get that like i know i
know most of people that recognize me in
person like don't watch my content right
now and that's fine like i don't expect
them to this guy right here stopped
watching my content he hasn't even
stopped watching his content yeah
you stopped posting for a long time well
it's because i fell off he he told me
like i came in here and he was like dude
you have got to get back on
the the wagon here
because he was giving me he he said he
picked the podcast jack he picked me up
by my by my shirt held me up it was some
super human strength wagon yeah yeah and
and he was any and then he slapped me a
couple times and he picked up your
machete
no we got a baseball bat too it's for oh
yeah
yeah home security gotcha
yeah funny story uh i so this was in
2018 too
it sounds like all of my cool stuff was
in 2018. this was not cool actually uh i
was working for a youtuber who
i like minecraft okay uh he did
minecraft videos and he had a little
channel called pink sheep
and
pink sheep was like
it was like an ai voice like
text-to-speech uh reading a script
whatever video
it was it was it's a kid's channel
um
but like
he hired me for
like the guy running it hired me for
like
like a month to just come up with ideas
and thumbnails and stuff for this
channel
and i don't think he turned down a
single one and one of them i was like
dude wouldn't it be funny if
pink sheep was in a tank and then he
tried to get out of the tank and then he
was just in a bigger tank
and they uploaded it they made a whole
like three minute long video out of it
that idea isn't three minutes long
why did he do that
i still
like that's analogous to something no it
didn't do well
no i always feel sorry if i give it an
idea and it doesn't do well why would it
do well i don't know i said it as a joke
yeah
it's about the channel
it's i don't remember like 400 000 subs
yeah i mean it's decent size yeah
yeah
it's it was it was an interesting day
i'm i'm kind of like proud of it because
it's like that's so funny that i did
that and i gave him that idea
and then he made the video and it didn't
work oh man yeah what are some other
ideas that you come up with
what do you mean by idea because that is
a broad spectrum because i have ideas
that are just so bad
oh i don't know um
oh man okay well there's
a youtube channel i made
um with a friend
called the official joined rock johnson
youtube channel and it's all just clips
of the same interview of dwayne the rock
johnson with a different punch line
edited from the clip
um and it's like it's got like 20 videos
and like the the top on the channel is
like 1.6 million
views wow that sounds like a great idea
yeah isn't it great
it's not bad i think that's no that's
that's not that's one of the good ones
i i i can't think of any at the moment
you know i have so many stupid ideas i
got an idea that uh that i think might
do well i don't know if i'm gonna do
this idea maybe at some point but uh i
use in the background a fireplace
sometimes in my videos and it's just a
fireplace real fire uh
no no it's on the computer but i put the
computer in the background i film it and
it kind of looks it blends in with the
background so it looks like there's a
flame going you've heard this thing
called green screen yeah
but i don't know you could put you can
put so many things on it difficult to do
an imovie but
do you use imovie
i used to use imovie it's good i use i
use imovie oh you think it's good i
think it's good why i like it
well that's fair yeah
he likes it do you use imovie he taught
me on imovie but i do i do final cut
oh
yeah wha what do you think of premiere
uh it it didn't like mesh well with
imovie because i knew imovie really well
and final cut was nice so i use it
what what do you think of anything
besides why why
everything i need is there it's like i
just need to cut zoom
b-roll
and text i do a png file done
everything i need to save so easy i
don't need anything else it's worked
and i guess i guess for me it's like
so much
of my videos rely on the edit so it's
like i i can't imagine trying to make my
videos in imovie yeah see mine's more
about the information yeah so when
you're just you know info like meet
kevin could just do a straight 20 minute
video of him just talking mm-hmm no cuts
down he's going to find a tutorial yeah
and then that could get like 200 000
views and he could post multiple there's
a lot of youtubers like that yeah i mean
if you could do that that yeah more
power to you i mean look at i mean i
don't know how much attention you pay to
youtubers but like critical
um
penguin zero yeah you know him yeah sits
down yeah white shirt but on a camera he
plants his videos so meticulous
sometimes i'd like how does he come up
with his content i don't know if he does
i think he
scripts out his videos or has a script
that he goes from
i know
uh
funny funny you mentioned this uh
ludwig do you know ludwig
uh he he has a channel called mogul mail
he he one takes all his videos sits down
in front of the camera like talks for
five ten fifteen minutes one takes it
every single time
it's crazy he talks well i can't do that
yeah i can't how do you do that yeah i
feel you script your videos yes
dang yeah every word is scripted but i
feel better because it's like when i
make a video it is boring and so sure if
i lose any retention at any point it's
clearly not a chance that boring you
know you you get lots of yeah because
they're so planned
because i plan it it's like if i riff
and i get off topic and someone loses
interest there's the video it's gotcha
interesting but anyway my my idea was
that because i had the fireplace thing
in the back
i could very easily create a channel of
just a fireplace loop
10 hours
um i listened the other night to white
noise cause the room was too quiet yeah
white noise
that had like 20 million views on this
video just really
for 10 hours
you just throw so many mid-rolls on that
but but then people listen to another oh
walmart
uh but like stuff like that uh there was
another one of just like the sound of
the rain
oh i love it like i love i love
listening like oh man you could do 10
hours of of all of those and just get a
channel where you know if i shouted it
out maybe it gets recommended and
people start listening to it i think
that would be nice yeah just upload like
clown clown
horn noises yeah
yeah you ever you ever see the like you
ever like download the sound effects off
of youtube yeah i do yeah all the time
like the spring noise like yeah i see we
don't use that in finance content oh
what if you did
it would be really fun and then you like
dress up in like a clown
suit i kevin did that though
really yeah oh man everyone's everyone's
got their niche
okay kevin did that too because he was
he was getting some some backlash for
selling all of his portfolios so people
were calling him a clown for doing that
so he was like yeah i'm gonna see a
clown i'll be a clown so he literally
wore a clown outfit in his video dang
but you know what the funny thing is
as soon as he leaned into it
the hate went away
i was shocked
but like i mean that's that i mean when
it's something basic like that you can
you can do that pretty easily
um if you own it yeah no no and yeah it
was it it's an interesting thing because
in the finance space there's not usually
any like drama that goes on there's very
little sure nothing so kevin selling was
like the biggest thing for finance like
in in that month
and it's interesting to see just first
of all how quickly within two weeks
everyone i don't say everyone like 90 of
people didn't care anymore um but then
as soon as he acknowledged people
calling him a flip-flopper he was like
yeah i'm a flip-flopper and then people
like well
uh
oh never mind you suck and it's like but
they went away and it's it's yeah and
then now it's like nothing ever happened
right um so plus i don't think the
reaction was necessarily warranted but
uh
anyway just it's just a good case at
least for him to lean into it and uh
then it takes away someone else's power
by doing that yeah do you think you
could ever
dress up in a clown suit probably not
and own it probably not no yeah
no i'm the kevin kevin's more of a
jokester and stuff like that so i i i
would be too serious to do that i
dropped it
i wouldn't be able to do it unless it's
like an april fool's video what what if
because you're so serious that's what
makes it funny though
well if you what if you don't
acknowledge it at all so he's boxing
michael reeves which is like wait wait
wait in the items event yeah with that
yeah you're boxing michael reeves
yeah and that's so out of character too
that's so so funny yeah
i wait how tall is michael same height
really
same weight
probably i feel like he's got to be a
little bit thinner than you maybe he's
he's so i mean where what yeah but we're
probably within five pounds right
interesting who do you think's gonna win
dude he's gonna come out with like a
chainsaw oh no no no you know okay so
you know those little like grabber toys
that you can get like that are like the
extension ones yeah yeah
but instead of it being one of the
grabber toys it's it's like a boxing
glove
see michael reeves i feel like
he's such a
you you can't like
can't pin him down because he's so smart
i think i think he beat him i think you
i think you bribe the refs with your
with your fat sticks but he's gonna find
a way to i don't know like i'm a little
worried about it because of how smart he
is and he
i don't say he has more time than me but
he could train more than i could
but you can say you can trick yourself
and say it's work
you ever think about it i could i could
i mean listen i want to win but uh
what do you get if you win i don't
actually know anything about no it's for
charity oh okay so i thought from
everything um you know it's just gonna
push me out of my comfort zone and do
something i would never do i just
thought 10 years from now i'd look back
and regret not doing it but then i also
am worried of like like i don't want to
get
i don't want to get hurt yeah dude
that's that's my thing it's like i'm
such like a wimp so so yeah so i've been
doing light sparring with the trainer
who wears these he wears these very like
super padded big gloves so that you know
they'll hate you but it's not like a hit
but still he hits you with those gloves
uh he's he did one to my stomach when i
wasn't expecting it uh because i put my
hands up too much
and like oh my gosh like that really
hurt and that was with the big gloves
and then he hit me once uh in the nose
and it's like it felt like i had sinus
pressure for the rest of the night like
it just and that was with the fat like
the kids gloves that you're just like
yeah kids will all you know like hit
each other with a
i'm telling you machete it's like
yeah just bring just just bring the
machete just bring the machete and
tasers but then the other thing too
someone can't stop you who's going to
stop who's going to stop you what do you
mean
when you bring the machete to the boxing
family yeah i get kicked out though why
he's not allowed they're scared of you
you're afraid to win
yeah no he he asked me if i i think i
think he asked me if i had any interest
and i was like no
but what if i could be a ref
or or a commentator or
a cheerleader yeah but why did you say
no
because i'm scared
but would don't you think that in the
future this would be a good thing for
you to learn how to box why because it
uh i i think it reinforces that you
could try something new and if you
succeed at it it's just positive
reinforcement for that
it's just a new experience
no
okay that's right just not for you no i
i no i i get you i just don't think
i don't think
i
have the motivation
to to make myself do that right now
i think if i if i wanted to do it i
would want to do it for something that
wasn't that i don't know why i think i
would want to do it for myself more than
anything yeah
yeah that's certain that's and that's
part of it for me too i just remember i
was talking to jack and maybe macy um
and we were talking about like boxing
matches like who would you box i said
the only person i bought is michael
reeves interesting and then it came up
like a year later
the opportunity i was like that's a sign
i have to do it why why why only michael
reeves because they're the same height
and i felt like it would be a very
matched
yeah uh event and fun yeah would it be
fun if it were yeah if it were anyone
else
like let's say uh uh like who else like
jesse from nelk it's about the same
height as me too
and
i wouldn't fight him because i know that
like i've seen how he is with fitness
and i know like i could i could never
reach that same all like i would just be
dead
what are you trying to say about michael
reeves yeah are you starting beef before
your fight
we're having them on on friday right
yeah we are oh really what
yeah guys congrats i'm a huge michael
reese fan why did nobody tell me one of
you has to pick him up from the airport
i want to pick him up from the airport i
i know michael though is he coming with
lily i don't know i did he said he's he
wanted so this is how dedicated michael
is to his video i'm not going to spoil
this video
he wanted and he was fully prepared to
fly to vegas
just to get a 10 second shot with me
oh yeah well he he does
he loves doing that yes
he did that yeah he did a giant road
trip for the boston dynamics dog but i
was blown away and and that's how this
started and then i asked well hey listen
you're coming all the way out here do
you want to be on the podcast yes
but still if it wasn't for that he was
he was talking about his flights
literally flying in driving to the house
getting a shot and then going right back
really yes what a freak yeah what a
freaking nation and then i was looking
at the times i'm like that's
gonna have like an hour
overlapping you see the time you're at
that house yeah he's like you well the
thing is he doesn't upload it's just
like right yeah his last video was
almost a year ago what is he doing
he said he does offline tv
streams
and he only makes a video if he's in the
mood to make a video which means that
if it works it works yeah yeah but if
that's his system but yeah but he's he's
got this down where it's like he only
needs to do one video a year
with a sponsor
and that's and that's it and then that's
more than a doctor makes it here but
that one video has to be perfect but
knowing him it is hey and he does like
the surgery robot and then he puts his
hand down
oh yeah he said i need i need you for 10
seconds for the meme
that's literally what he said
that sounds like you know what it's just
like he did it that's exactly what he
would say oh my gosh
i don't know him i don't know him very
well that's exactly what he would say
yeah
so anyway what questions you have for us
um so i did a merge company sort of here
and there called pool hall and like
at the end of the day how much do you
think a youtuber needs to be involved in
the in the
um
business of what they're making because
i felt like
at the time i wasn't doing enough of
like
the ideation or any of that for for
creating the merch
um
and
i had late a guy named lay installer did
all the designs and and
um they helped me make it a real thing
and it i i thought it was great
i was very proud of it but i didn't feel
at the end of the day like i did that
much for it
and i'm curious if you feel the same
thing when making
something like that like bankroll coffee
how much do you feel like you put
towards it and how proud of it are you
proud of bankroll coffee because it
looks and tastes really good um
but i also
am in line with my partner noel on that
and we have like the same sort of
aesthetic so whatever he does i know i'm
happy with it um but as far as merch
goes it's a lot tougher because are
people buying it just to support you
right or is the design good what about
the branding is it only branded because
they know you or can it stand on its own
uh the only two merch companies i really
like are nelk
they've done incredible with full send
but they're so involved in that because
they weren't making money anywhere else
it was just the merch so they had to be
because that was how they made money and
danny duncan us
you know we used so many
shirt brands and
logos and stuff like that but danny
duncan did a really good job at that too
gotcha but he was kind of similar he
never did sponsors he uh wouldn't make
any money from advent very little so he
did merch but he was so involved in that
gotcha interesting
so
so
do you how much do you think a youtuber
needs to be involved in in what they're
making probably like decent enough they
want to be like it depends if are they
happy making a few grand a month selling
selling merch to their fans who want to
support them then probably they don't
need to do that much but if they want to
evolve and grow it into something a lot
bigger they have to be but then you also
have to think is merch really the best
roi for your time
for a lot of people it's probably not
it's probably you're better off just
getting a sponsor do you think that's
fine as a youtuber to do or yeah
i mean if i was making no money and the
coffee is the only thing i had i would
be put i would not only push that but i
tried to like expand it
t we we would have tea by now we would
have had k-cups
um but you know it's just gross slower
because it's not necessarily like the
main focus
interesting interesting much to think
about yeah
i've thought about i've thought about
making like a a merch company um
to like distribute clothes but like
everyone does that yeah the margins are
so thin yeah so everyone's doing it you
don't want to do something that everyone
else is doing it unless you have like a
very easy in or you have a way to do it
better than somebody else literally the
main reason i want to is because i like
wearing the clothes that
like i make
like i like the stuff that we made for
pool hall but not well yeah i'm looking
at this i mean
this is not i i put together this outfit
for just for this podcast uh
i was not gonna wear it i was not gonna
wear any anything that
was call me carson branded or anything
like that um
but uh i like having
joggers that have my little brand on it
you know just i like i like when it's
comfortable and when i've made it
or like given the quality pass on it
and i think that's the main reason i
want to make merch it's just so i could
wear it yeah maybe i should just make
merch for myself
but then
i wear it and then people are like i
wanna i wanna i want that so it's like
and sell it yeah then sell it but like
the margins are so thin
did you find it profitable yeah it was
very profitable
but that was back then this is how much
were you making back then
oh
we made
oh i don't know
i want to say
first drop was like
i don't know i like um i think i'm gonna
lowball it here but
above 40k okay
pretty pretty good how long does it take
you to sell that first drop
i i don't remember this was so long ago
i'm so sorry that's fine it's fine uh
i'm curious if this were like a day or
like a week no it was probably it was
probably like a week i think i think we
had too many products um for the first
launch and then the second launch i
think there was less
like like we we
dropped the first launch and there was
like there's a bunch of cool items but
there were probably too many and then we
did the second um
where we did like a little october
launch and it was like
uh it was it was um like more spooky
themed
you know
just darker or close
and that did not sell as well because i
think it was a little bit too soon after
the first drop
um
but i
i i haven't done much
in in that vein and i want to i want to
expand like my my business know-how and
and make something cool like that that i
can
like sell to people because i i think
it's fun any other questions any final
questions you want to bring in no i'm
good thanks for having me on i
appreciate it so much it was a pleasure
would you leave vegas um fridays oh yeah
today are you a whole week yeah we could
we could find a time then to to hang out
at some point today i'd like that i'd be
down yeah okay cool cool awesome
thank you this is this was legitimately
very fun thank you guys for having me on
but did you get your free stock down
below in the description when you sign
up for public using the good gram i
don't know
just say yes
i'd love to do that just say you're
getting i'd love
[Laughter]
actually yeah oh yeah someone got a free
stock of tesla by the way
really yeah it was like 800 bucks
yeah it's it's up to a thousand so most
people when they sign up will get like
three to twenty usually
uh but yes i'm gonna share tesla that's
pretty cool so anyway thank you so much
make sure to subscribe hit the like
button
we'll put all of our information down
below in the description where they
could subscribe to you too and you oh
thank you i appreciate it oh yeah i'll
i'll post
i might do it like a thing
all right till next time
you